I see that turkey winking at me hi
turkey face Thanksgiving in our family
is the main event
we give things every single day but
that's this special thing for that it
came from a large family everybody got
together on Thanksgiving everyone who
doesn't have a place to go we say come
oh you have to have a turkey yeah it's a
tradition oh my goodness no Turkey no
Thanksgiving the turkey is the main not
for me if it's not kosher
I don't eat it my sister a to the man
upstairs wait a second
Oh God okay uh-huh
do you have the turkey here I can't wait
wait hola that's Thanksgiving yeah
what's the sorry Studies on that peaches
on side this turn right or the turkey
looks nuts now watch me cut it and watch
me let me see photos in my mouth my
mouth actually it's an interesting
combination
oh is it let me look at your mouth it's
okay and who doesn't know his way now
heathyr keys no a lot of bourbon in it
no one it tastes better than I didn t
just we will taste it again and taste
like regular Turkey this is not a saw as
an oven baked turkey how do you fry a
big turkey you must have to have a big
pot this is siliceous i might try the
new turkey it's compatible it's good no
more my sister is going to insist that I
eat it because she enjoys watching me
put the pounds on but that's okay it's
okay
hey wait wait let me look at it first a
circular turkey is that gristle what
what stuffing
okay I'm warning you I get sick you
tasted I'm gonna see what that is watch
my sister watch me everyone here goes
gobble gobble hmm
not bad Oh things that you don't think
you know it's hurting you chicken and
duck turkey duck and chicken third Duffy
who I never heard of that
I don't think real people do this it was
anything before but what is this I'm
obsessed with this piece of fat when I
first saw it I didn't want to come the
ers tasted it twice more than passable I
can tell a little bit in delicious
episodic you know low yeah call me
though my wisdom my review of turducken
is a seven cuz the fat I think I want my
sister to take another sniff sniff I can
do let us snip at it while I eat it I
sniff it sniff it little doggie oh it
does smell good yes I don't
oh that's Turkey and I think it likes
find a delicious what's on the outside
cuz that's really tough I don't know
what is this it's almost like I don't
like that No Mas I think I will give
this one to my sister yeah you'll have
to tell me what that is it's supposed to
be of a Kannada pronounced beggin beggin
dushman
so it's basically tofu okay
that's why to me on Thanksgiving I would
never look at this dish that's a very
weird taste thing I would know make that
I think this is a dish if you are on a
desert and you are looking for something
to eat a my review of different but toe
turkey is a one you could use some of my
language if you'd like it's freaking bad
oh my goodness we almost got her to come
over to my side what I had to serve any
of these turkeys what is this one that I
liked true Duncan to Duncan I would go
for the turducken to Durkin to chicken
it was turkey chicken and duck I would
serve it and know that my family weird
wait one second my normal family members
would like it I go back to the
traditional one I think there's
something about tradition that's very
important but truthfully occasion
you could either try something different
it is not with that tofu stuff let's try
a different type of turkey and see what
that feels like so that we just don't go
through life trying one thing we shall
experience as much as we can a chocolate
Turkey would be the best for me I love
it idea that's my best going a little
chocolate Turkey and finally and I eat
okay that's a good at gobble gobble
gobble gobble
call me ask you something that's the way
you're gonna show the turkey no boy
you're gonna put it on the turkey